citizens of the recheck Nation so Tara and
Andrew they don't really know each other
they got very different
styles very different Energies
but neither of them have seen the Meg see
how this goes get comfortable you know be
vulnerable have fun drink some work have
fun and that's my part and I'll see you
guys later thank you Tara why don't you do
the intro since you're here more often okay
and it's me Tara Erickson joined by this
guy I don't know say your name uh my name
I forgot it Andrew Gordon what's going on
Gordon wow all right cool name Andrew Gordon
uh you've never seen the Meg and mean either
so we've bonded over that at least right yes
we're gonna watch this movie together don't
forget to like comment and also ring the bell
worrying about when you subscribe were you
surprised by the song and try just did Andrew did
you know that that was my thing I would say yes
but since I watched your last of us reactions same
side we're already we're already buddies and don't
forget guys when you're on patreon watch along
with sync up just be a patron because then you
can watch the whole thing with me and him see how
we're bonding not bonding being cool being uncool
watching the make doing some shark stuff uh and
I think that's it do I say more stuff Andrew no
let's watch Jason Statham versus a shark do it yes
[Music]
thank you yeah there he is that
shark does not stand a chance
Jason Statham
sew that up buddy headed back
to the rescue vehicle now
I have no idea there's something
[Music]
going with the Alfred Hitchcock approach of
not showing the shark I like it you okay pal
foreign oh my goodness this is amazing
uh
wow all right cold-hearted he's like
all of us goners or just a couple sorry
if we go back everyone dies he's doing the
right thing even though it seems so mean yes
Mana one what are you doing come on bring it
in let's go Frain Wilson oh my goodness with
these glasses on I thought it was Josh Gad I do
remember my daughter our chief marine biologist
[Music]
you know I realize that we're under
construction and everything but I
really think that a world-class Research
Institute deserves a world-class entrance
sick oh you were eating those words right now
bro this is our Central Hub which researchers
will access all five flaps wow look at the
humpback whale I love them this is giving
me some deep blue sea Vibes yeah this is Lucy
and her daughter Gracie uh oh gosh yeah I was
thinking I was like are they gonna I was like they
don't get mad our engineering sub designer Jax doc
oh John Wick 2 and I think Batwoman and Orange is
the New Black I think this is our first Ruby Rose
yes Ruby Rose since 1875 the Mariana Trench was
the deepest place on Earth what do we think is
the bottom but actually the layer of hydrogen
sulfide if there's warm water below that means
we're going to be the first to see it and what
if you're wrong then you have wasted 1.3 billion
dollars and I will be fired origin crew we are go
for insertion we are a gopher insertion so dumb
it's a movie pre early establishes the toned
yeah right I mean you got just the idea to see
them versus the Megalodon in general but yeah
it is not the bottom Lori be careful we don't
know the depth on the other side of the sea floor
can come right up on you so the 1.3 billion was
not wasted because they were right Lorraine Wilson
should be doing jumping jacks yeah I'm like why is
he not stoked you're through well I have multiple
small sonar contacts deploying the lights [Music]
jellyfish
free coffee that's cool it's like Wally but
under the sea this ecosystem is completely
cut off from the rest of the ocean
but the freezing cold Thermo climb
uh bearing zero eight to
zero damn it's moving fast
all right let's get into it we'll
try and bring up some more lights
no soon
oh my God
Jonas was right
around his sorrows in the bottle I mean
that's how I would spend my vacay too now
this is shaping up to be an eventful Tuesday
evening you know I like to make an entrance
make up the five years just showing up is making
an entrance once you're living above a bar really
that's my dream living above a bar oh yeah
prime time you're gonna offer me money I'll
still say no why don't we sit down we'll enjoy
a couple of beers and then we can get you on
your way it's like he's watched a bunch of
horror movies this happened this morning
you didn't say you wouldn't listen to a voice
recording and not do it so here we go buddy
Salon is planned your ex-wife and a crew are
trapped below 11 000 meters possibly dead I
have divers with less experience willing to
go but I feel I owe it to my crew to give
this rescue the best chance of success so we're
going for a ball drunk guy leave the beer behind
and save them would be kind of entertaining to
watch the shark I bet you he'd be the best one
because he was like loosed up and ready to go I
can probably reboot the computers okay try now
auxiliary powers back what are you doing taking
notes to my wife just in case he's a realist she's
very pretty no all the women in this movie are
very pretty got a candlelights damn that's tough
having a cheeseburger pen they're really hot I
mean it's interesting they're really holding on
to this oh yeah I only noticed once you set up
another leaking oxygen we've got a couple hours
one of the gliders drop the origin
and tore her up if the origins Palace
tanks blow you're gonna die too
we have to okay girl go get him
[Music]
Mama Trudeau
Alex that was a good like heartfelt moment I
like both of those little actresses they're good
well that thing is awesome yeah all
the stuff with like the underground
submarine type stuff like that's all really good
oh my gosh I felt like I was like in that I want
that to be a ride I was just about to
say right I'd be so down to do that oh
as long as there's no no megalodons in the water
oh man but that would make it fun as long as they
just don't like they can bump us around a little
bit like a fun game of bowling but like you're
not allowed to eat us as long as I know Jason
Statham is somewhere in the water protecting
me I guess that'd be good okay it's got to be
one of the Jason's either him or Jason Momoa
oh oh he's in perfect shape just like the last
time you accidentally he's in perfect shape with
all that alcohol all right he's been drinking 25
beers a day like damn how do I get on that diet
we're in international waters which means legally
I can be the evil living [__] out of you and get
away with it because I'm Jason Statham illegally
I mean good thing it doesn't hold a grudge
Cliff Curtis is such a great actor really
believable always really grounded yeah
oh oh girl what are you doing you must be the
crazy guy no call me there everyone um Dr Heller
yeah well I'm not crazy I'm just drunk hey crazy
is my mom gonna die I've kept him bubbles in your
mum back in no time I promise it's kind of star
wars-esque like when they're in the back of the
thing it's like the seat moves the same oh yeah
yeah good point system go for descent to go
come on face your fears face your fears
break out a bear you'll get over it
this way you should have brought down there
come on you gotta go save your ex-wife buddy
I thought he was gonna pull up and then end
credits oh the end [Music] oh man please
don't like crash into her do you know what
you're doing buddy entering thermal climb
oh that has to hurt well and also the speed
he's going yeah it's like probably should be
illegal right because you should be
doing it slow otherwise you get but
the speed I'm gonna have to divert power
from shut down anything that got us over
he needs a hybridberg chamber is it still
out there I can't I can't see anything right
now always best way to see if something big is
outside is to put a water cup on the dashboard to
really block The View oh no you mean like to see
through it gives you like better I was thinking of
Jurassic Park when the wrecks was oh yeah stomping
the grounds that's how you know something you're
watching you're watching the cup if it vibrates
I got you now I've got visual other words okay
don't turn on your lights that's bad fiery
magnetic hook three two see Daisy [Music]
oh nice save
oh my God yeah they are so strong like is
she gonna just be eaten by a squid right now
oh shoot your target thing out inside of his mouth
right I mean you'd waste the turtle
oh good yep that's some Squid Ink so
damn cool it's so big
yes it's like 20 25 meters okay that
she was gonna say Fido's like that's
way more than that right but that was a nice
Jaws reference right there cut them off now
15 seconds I have no control uh-oh oh my goodness
oh okay he's doing flares or something
oh cool smart nice really he's a hero
get out of there your thoughts is clear I'm
headed for the origin now regardless of what
anyone thinks of this movie The underwater
stuff is shot really well it's awesome yeah
foreign
cool I want one of those I wanted
her to say something like yeah
that's probably my ex we better get out
of the way he's a loose cannon like with
the dialogue so far in this film I
would have expected that one right
she's coming if that thing hits us while we're
still attached does he have to make the tough
decision again I know right all right you guys
stay down here good luck we'll come back for you
hurry it up guys come on now oh gosh oh my gosh he
wrote the letter to his wife oh he just couldn't
use it he knows it oh yeah we should have saw
that foreshadowing oh he's gonna sacrifice
[Music]
this poor guy
I mean doesn't that also hurt the Megalodon up in
his mouth does that explosion not harm it at all
to it it's all burnt up it just like
makes him scarier well they actually
did that in Jaws too where the shark got
a little bit burnt up oh and it had like
this really scary scar on the side of its
face I hope he doesn't blame Jason Statham
again he's like dude this guy sacrificed
himself it's not my fault yeah right
proof is in the pudding in this letter he
was ready you couldn't bring Toshi back
they really they really are blaming him he
saved us two other witnesses that say no you
are the guy who leaves people behind you go
that deep you take your life in your hands
it's your choice a fair argument
I want to apologize for before
my temper and you did save my naked all those
muscles that shark stands no change no chance look
at those abs there's like 17 of them so thank you
I know it's not easy being the person who survives
you should put on some clothes yep it's the
original plan okay then carry on oh boy so corny
some of the writing in here I'm like that's a
great singer and some of it I'm like why would
they add that and like the heartfelt moment she
had with her daughter was great and this is not
and then there's other scenes where it's like
yeah tone is like do we go into a Nickelodeon
channel scene kind of this is what attacked
us damn Megalodon seven inches 70 and 90 feet
70 and 90 feet largest truck that ever exists
holy junk it feared to nothing oh my God
hey crazy now that we've actually found something
amazing thank you for keeping your promise
it's just so sweet it's like literally the hardest
to film so far like I really feel when she talks
I'm like I love her if you're still selling
people back down there don't call me to come
save your asses Man versus maid is in a fight it's
a Slaughter so man's gonna win especially if that
man is Jason Statham yeah with his 17 ABS yeah
so many I mean if the shark just saw those abs
it would turn them around like no chance then
he would just scream go tell the other sharks
is very peaceful but I feel like something
is bad this is science is building
uh oh my God oh my God oh my oh whoa spooky
that's gonna be the other alternative
[Music] so it means it has now crossed
the barrier and is now coming up top because
Dave haven't seen it that high before yes
curious to see the damage it cost yeah like where
is it is it like leaking oh do you see the teeth
damn that glass is so strong I mean obviously to
withstand water pressure but yeah Megalodon teeth
[Music]
oh my gosh that legitimately scared me yeah oh no
poor whales oh no humpback go hide I don't want
you to get eat I feel like let me let me let me in
like save me I don't like it it's sad oh circle of
life just think about the circle of life it was
one degree Celsius right yeah but a minute later
when the evolution came up the temperature
increased by 25 degrees a shark could come
right through there oh because there was those
weird seismic things they were down there yeah
these sharks have no fins they were killed by
shark poachers it's disgusting that people do
that why do they do that I hate those people they
should be put to death normally I don't want the
shark to this Meg to eat people but in this case
it'll make an exception those people eat them all
like I'm glad I hope the Meg did eat them all
if we can shoot the mag in a soft spot like his
mouth or gills we can inject it with something
lethal it's gonna take at least 20 minutes to
rig the cage nothing will be gone at two the
cage you have a cage that big there's no way
safest way to approach is without a vehicle
hold up one of us alone in the water is no
okay who the hell is gonna make that swim I
can't swim it's okay you just sit there and
save your money if I get eaten you don't
feel really bad all right he's insane to
jump in the water but he Statham he can do
it that's true he's got 17 ABS he's good
oh my goodness oh my God I can't believe he's
just like just the fins always get me like
oh boy it's going under [Music]
why didn't you bring goggles sir uh
that might have been a good idea yeah
oh there you go good okay you're Tara
thank goodness okay I'm listening it
would literally if that was me
there would be a lot of brown
laughs
take it back bring me back yeah yeah shoot it and
then I guess run run in water why do a water run
oh got it right right can they really
like really that's not gonna be good
for the shark to see you better keep your
body straight as [__] oh no vibration
screw that get the vibration
oh [__] did they say how fast it can
go the shark no but like we saw it oh
wow that's insane oh man I will get you in
here and your 17 ABS yes this is awesome
oh he's out of there oh is he
underground like forget about it
oh my God holy junk that was crazy okay
same time tomorrow be a son of a [__]
but you sure as hell no cow good job you got guts
yeah but just because he's not a coward doesn't
mean he's not dumb yeah but I guess I can't call
him dumb because he succeeded so he did he did
his job and I feel like him and what is her name
I forgot it already a little bit of love connect
right then when he was back home I thought the
foreshadowing was when he was connecting with her
daughter and like is this going to be a surrogate
father totally remind me again was a good idea
what it's a shark cage plastic showcase I'd
want mine to be like 10 000 times bigger than
that before I get in the water that's too small
polycarbonate specifically designed not to crack
maybe talking about breaking that's eight to nine
hundred thousand I don't like it doesn't like it
I wouldn't get in there exactly I'm with him I'm
not getting in there either either of us I know
about this can penetrate the Megalodon skin let
me go don't worry about me let me do what I do
best I kind of wish she spoke in Chinese more in
this because when she does she's talking to her
daughter in Chinese right yes and I really believe
I was like with it more like I know but then he
couldn't understand her she stays them he probably
speaks every language I know right like maybe he's
just a guy who's like I know a little bit and then
they have conversations I think that would have
been cool that would have been a nice connection
too yeah yeah right so you you know tastes good
thank you bye-bye good luck I'm glad
he's in a joking mood after his friend
was just annihilated totally he was
so serious at the meeting table now
he's just like oh this is no big deal
so yeah just another's day work yeah
they're like yeah heck yeah give me this
food you all better get out of there
oh yeah they sense the big one
coming they're like we're out
good luck lady come on come on come
on it's on its way 50 meters 50 meters
I figure it would be visible
by now right like it's funny
how they're like always looking
around and then all of a sudden
that's not that's fighting dirty sir
oh my God whoa that thing is gnarly it
also looks really old and like wrinkly
look he's got like wrinkles amazing is that
foreshadowing in the eye just saying I don't know
oh he's coming back angry
oh it's gonna pull that puppy off the chain yeah
they didn't really think this plan really didn't
you better cut that cord you're gonna have to let
her go otherwise it's gonna take down the boat
oh good girl where'd she where'd she hit him
I think she hit him in his like get gills
oh that didn't do much that cage will not
break that's the problem the cake is being
swallowed oh you guys didn't think about
that part oh yep he's just gonna oh God
did you hear rain Wilson
he said hell yeah he's like
speaking for the audience I love it I love that
wait is he ever a tank down there do you just go
without it I think he went without it right yeah I
think he just went with like a god like a goggle
thing yeah I don't know I didn't see [Music]
[Music]
uh-oh okay good enough distraction oh wait he he
does have the the tank on oh he does okay okay
my mouth gets broken oh no I'm losing air
okay well it's all right 17 I'm Gonna Save
you oh no somebody help her hello yeah are
you how are you guys not looking around for
the woman who fell out of the boat okay she's
maybe not dead ah hurry hurry come on Jackson
oh my goodness no Jonas go get back to the ship
is he gonna give her his oxygen
tank kind of like Star-Lord did
for Gamora in space probably because he
could probably free dive too like once
he has enough air he'll probably we're
gonna set a track guys I need some bait
oh God it's right there oh good
he's going for the bait come on
why would you be holding on to the chain
I also would not be anywhere near the edge
right like be in the middle of the boat come
on guys whoa that's spooky oh oh my goodness
oh did the thing finally kick in
is it dead no like the stuff she
gave him finally kicked in maybe the meds
come on now let Statham do it oh right
that guy's a doctor well like he'll
do that I forgot yeah Jason do the
bear part yeah I'm sure that's how
she would prefer it anyways yeah right
because something you might want to see
what they call they caught what it what oh
okay so they did Kill the shark oh my goodness
that's why I thought it was that but you want a
proper picture get your head inside no way that
little amount was like lethal come on get in okay
I thought we're making jokes right now [Applause]
oh my God I would not put my head anywhere near
that thing oh also where is this prop
I need to go see it next to the mic
oh was it different is he saying they're
different or smaller what I'm thinking we did
what people always do discover and then destroy
what are you supposed to do to leave this thing
alive I mean come on he was gonna kill him I
agree with what he's saying about it but not
in this case come on also you have a huge like
living fossil it also belongs in a museum yeah
oh my god oh he just jumped on the boat tamale
y'all thought you caught and destroyed that
puppy still living damn well that was like
the first Jaws they remember they caught
that shark and thought it was it was the tiger
shark yeah the real woman was out there still
whoa and obviously the shark jumping onto the
boat like Jaws yes yeah a lot of like references
right everything I mean that's the point that's
the goat of course you're gonna reference that
movie oh my God tip the whole boat over whoa what
get out of here in the middle of the ocean yeah
destroying 75-foot megalodons
wasn't no I don't know
you're dead still has to be alive right yeah see
them just saving everybody he really is I'm Queen
that line reminds me of the line at the end
of Deep Blue Sea where Thomas Jane goes man
I tell you I quit this job yeah I the other
line of with that he said like this isn't
part of the job description this wasn't part
of the job is like from one of I don't know
I can't think of the movie it's like one of
those like Classics I do remember that line
I just don't remember I'm sure I'm sure
the lovely people will let us know in the
comments but I do remember that line I'm just
oh that's gonna kill me now what yeah you're
gonna be okay wait what the doctor's gonna
go go is he gonna sacrifice himself oh yeah
okay but you're the doctor you could save
people and they got hurt but all right buddy
one easy gulp I wonder if he's still swimming
around in there because that thing is oh oh my
God was that two that was a major blood trail I
don't think he's still swimming in there Orpheus
it's in pieces no I mean like swimming in his
stomach like it is like his mouth and his like
I don't think that's that's jet engine is not
probably Good Vibration right oh maybe
it's okay okay better to be on that than
the sinking boat but sure not not
feel good in that thing either yeah
good news guys it's payback time
whoa they're gonna try and shoot it
[Music]
sure jump up for the helicopter it's gonna like
why haven't you already started shooting at it
but what are you what are they doing oh in Jaws
2 the shark actually did eat a helicopter oh dope
pretty hysterical actually oh you're just gonna
make him mad another tracker we already know
where it's at well I think we have that
you're gonna blow it up I was gonna say
I think the tracker also was on the other
one that got killed right oh you're right
too much water got in his lungs is that what
happened I don't know I mean maybe that was
a great little scene yeah that's right I like
it when the movie is being more serious yeah
I mean I know it's it a Megalodon shark it
works yeah but but like it doesn't have to
be you know the other part of the tone of the
movie is like we could still be there just not
as corny mixed with like that moment I really
felt yeah not as corny and not as much like
tone it down a little bit Yeah like like a good
30 and then we're in believable land yeah yeah
I love my two best friends to die you know
just about the ones you lose it's also about
the ones you save definitely saved a lot more than
he's lost yeah but they act like it's the opposite
yeah a lot of times I thought that was a good
scene rounded believable like good emotion Chinese
are sending two destroyers to take it out and an
evacuation ship is coming here tomorrow morning
I came here to celebrate with you and now I'm
mourning with you another good sense it's funny
it's like it's like the the like we said like the
emotional scenes that are like grounded and really
realistic like it actually hit yeah told me about
you and suyen can I believe how about you just
just try something [Music] product placement yeah
Coca-Cola we are not getting within a mile of that
monster until the helicopter kills it why is rain
Wilson even going out here yeah I'm like you're
the billionaire you're home hire the teams but
watch it on a video camera or something that's
what I mean like for him I'm like shouldn't you be
home I hope like oh he just like wanted to see it
we got him oh no you didn't you
barely broke the skin hit it again
well that's already that's the yeah what is that
oh jump down there give me a couple of teeth big
ones from my desk oh my God it looked like a
squid it looked like a squid I could be wrong
easy oh
oh sharks are eating it yeah and they're not
cannibals like would sharks eat another dead
shark oh well Megalodon oh damn that's
yeah that's part of me thing doesn't have
any teeth we kill the whale that's what I
was saying it was a whale or a squid yeah
yeah bye bye billionaire good luck
yeah that's right it's fine he's gonna eat you
and the squid at the same time buddy that will
not save you that's awesome oh he didn't
get oh what oh he just went through the uh
laughs
wow whoa I think his hand was still alive yeah
didn't call anyone no one knows the Sharks
out there oh oh wow the hell was he thinking
he wanted to make this go away as quietly as
possible oh yeah investors that's yeah makes
sense we're really gonna do this a lot of people
are gonna die if we don't make how do you feel
about coming during that Evac ship well I'd say
uh it's a great day to go fishing 20 minutes can
you get there first doubtful yeah we're gonna
have to getting there first one mean anything
if we don't have a plan maybe we have a plan
just Jason say them yeah swim in the water and
kill this thing how are we gonna get it here when
there's a beach full of people to eat right here
you ask it out for dinner oh so
they play the sound from the boat
oh my God that is a lot of people and they're
really deep in the water too tamale I have
never seen an ocean look like that where there's
that many people actually in the ocean no not the
dog no not you do not show a dog getting eaten
I will be so upset no get the dog out of the
water oh my God it's eat literally any person
do not eat the dog seriously if you do that
I'm I'm just oh no I can't no there's a little
puppy dog oh my God somebody grabbed the dog
hey that dog is out now just swimming
why is no one like fervently swimming
behind it to try to get the dog oh my
God swim and chill no no no no no no
no no no no don't get the puppy dog
no no no did it I don't like it okay
I hope this isn't an ALICE kittner
situation like in Jaws one remember
the kid who won the yellow raft yes I
said Mom just 10 more minutes oh my god oh
is the dog still alive that's what we want I
don't care about any of these people except
maybe the kid I want him to live yeah yeah I mean
the kids any kids but that that one he's very cute
oh that's not good whoa yeah he's
gonna eat that ball that's gonna
be fun for him to play with bounce
that around Mega [__] oh my gosh
this ocean is there is a lot going on
a lot of targets for the shark yeah
I really do love all those POV shots yeah
yeah it's cool oh no the tracker sayonara
trackie damn it that's not good nope oh
but is it dragon and anchor now oh no um
time to get off that thing yeah
oh gosh it's got both of them now oh okay
yeah that was a funny delivery of the lineup
sometimes I think it's some of the direction in
this movie that maybe the people would normally
like deliver certain things that way but maybe
they're being directed a certain way right
oh my God you could literally
just swallow like 50 people yeah
there we go see you later oh
oh yep she's cut in half whoa oh
oh my God the kid oh my goodness oh yay the sound
if I was one of those people who were fortunate
enough yeah I would never ever go to the ocean
ever again yeah it's swimming pools for me
the rest of my life yeah yeah if that even
that water is probably gonna traumatize me because
I'm just gonna think about that shark yeah look up
oh he's just gonna eat it like that
what's wrong join us come make the shot it's
too close to the ship oh my God Jonas what's
going on down there try to stay out of its
mouth that's a good idea oh he's gonna oh cool
oh he could just hide here
uh
oh no dang always gotta add now some kind
of an obstacle in this movie yeah nice yeah
[Music] can't see the shock but
something's going on up here
I think this is a moment where you get your shot
there's a lot of helicopters present here we come
bastard
oh my goodness
at least it's working again yeah yeah
damn he had a clear shot too gosh
[Music]
uh what you guys need to
watch where you're driving oh
[Music]
and this was not even the Megalodon's fault this
is because you dum-dums weren't looking where you
were going I mean guys who are with the cameras
look at the shark and the guy flying pay attention
in the air like what this was not a well thought
out plan okay I'm leading it away from the ship
get the little girl out of the water yeah come
on now jacket on a life jacket oh look at her
she's helping him I love how she's calming him
down no don't worry about the bus I got you
I got you she she might be my favorite character
she might be my favorite character mine hands down
she's beautifully written and performed yeah
like her little character Arc and how strong
she is and like is perfect are you gonna kill
it evolution I'm gonna make this thing bleed see
and we said before you were right it's not about
the people you lose it's about the ones you save
that's about the bippy is safe oh he's gonna
sacrifice himself like was he gonna fly into
his mouth and turn off the flares there's
flares right that's what I would do fly into
his mouth set off all the flares nothing like
playing chicken with a Megalodon right [Music]
that's much cooler than what I thought
that was sick how had nobody thought
of that before that was awesome
[Music]
it's got to be bleeding to death
yeah I mean he got a good chunk
oh
my that shot is insane oh the eyes
I yeah he's gonna stab it right in
its eye yeah because remember he
pointed the laser at it earlier
[Applause]
oh
awesome I know when sharks attack they
always close their eyes to protect their
eyes but the reason I said earlier
is this possible foreshan because
he was pulling the laser and the
shark was like blinking its eyes
oh oh they're all attacking it now because it's
mortally wounded that's a lot of sharks oh my
goodness Glock 17 abs they don't care about him
they're going for the the main meat yeah get her
oh my god oh but don't eat somebody's gonna eat
the explosion thing oh my turn to save you yeah
[Music] oh that is uh look at
him swimming out of its mouth
that's crazy that is food for weeks yeah months
foreign [Applause] get the doggy I've never
been so happy in my life thank goodness at
least the writers had enough common
sense of decency that dog better be
living I like that the Callback was
much later he's just still swimming
nothing like a shark bringing people and families
together right from Megalodon to Mega family
yay yay clits onto Mega family love it that's
going to be the next title the new movie
oh oh I was like I I got nervous there is
it the end where's the Royal credits okay
did it say Finn the way it's Finn like Finn
means the end but it's in not in the language
that any of it was spoken in right isn't Finn
like I'm in shark fin right I mean oh right
uh I don't know there you go I was like isn't
that French or like Le Finn whatever it is um
oh my God oh boy oh right I should pause this yeah
or we can just turn the volume down I think this
yeah the orange one oh my God that was so much fun
it was fun I mean it was corny and cheesy as hell
but I mean the whole idea of Jason Statham versus
a megalodon you're gonna get cheesy and corny as
hell but I will say for his cheesing corny as it
was I really did appreciate like the few scenes
where there was drama and um of course tension
stuff like that but those scenes with uh shoes Yen
her father and her daughter like I mean when they
were like grounded in reality and just having like
dramatic moments like I actually really enjoyed
those things I know everyone's like but the shark
scenes were your favorite right right they were
entertaining but like those are the scenes like
that I was relating to the most and the scenes
like I was invested in the most the rest was
just bombastic ridiculous fun entertaining stuff
but like in terms of serious stuff I enjoyed
the most I know I don't know why I'm picking
that but it was in my opinion it was the best
and uh that I enjoyed the most of it oh yeah I
mean I enjoyed the shark stuff a lot like I mean
I was screaming yelling the entire time because I
think it looks so awesome but I agree I'm like
oh if this film had more of that emotionality
and those characters who are very grounded I
really liked it when they spoke and they're
like native language I really like I don't know
I just really liked her performance a lot more
um but uh I think if they could have found a way
to add that seriousness into the whole script and
sure you can have jokes but not lay it on so
thick like make it more like just technical
we're down here even from the beginning it was
already like insertion and it was like oh are
we really doing aren't we isn't that like old
new old news I was gonna say old News Bears
um I just felt like it was old kind of jokes
that they were using that is like that's such
an easy go-to like what writer in the room
wasn't like maybe should make that better
but also how is this gonna play overall to these
great scenes that we have that add emotion and
depth to it but but mixed with I know you want
comedy because then it makes it fun but like
I didn't it wasn't as grounded yeah I might get
I mean this is I'm just making a hyperbole in uh
guess here but my guess is they're like look this
whole idea of this movie is ridiculous in general
so we're just gonna have fun uh just throw a lot
of light-hearted jokes in here and stuff like
that but to your point I just think if they would
about I think the key word is balanced yeah you
could have balanced the tone a little more I would
have taken this and I know again the whole idea
of Jason Statham versus a 75-foot shark is just
again on its face like that's ridiculous but right
still like I could have if you would have had more
scenes like that with in terms of tone with some
light-heartedness of course you can have jokes
like I'm not saying don't put humor in the film
right I just think that would have gone a long
way because a lot of times too and again I'm not
a writer I don't claim to be one I have massive
respect for writers I know it's a very difficult
job I have attempted to do it it's not easy yeah
um but a lot of this it wasn't even the it's just
a lot of the lines I'm like you guys are trying
to be way too smart for you I'm good I'm like
just calm down calm down here a little bit but
it was like if you do it once or twice it's like
okay whatever but when you're constantly doing it
and it's not you can try and be smarter than you
think if you're executing it properly but if it's
not executed properly it now it becomes a little
Annoying that's what I was gonna say that it might
be the direction too because if a lot of those
lines were more thrown away yeah even from the
beginning like insertion and nobody paid attention
to it and was just like you're going with that
again Sam great uh insertion but it was delivered
a different way rather than uh kind of put on like
put on like we're saying a joke and we're gonna
show her saying a joke and that didn't happen a
lot that was only a couple instances that I was
like that seems corny but there was some in here
where I legitimately laughed via the delivery that
was just very off the cuff and I thought it was
great um I thought uh I thought a lot of people in
here were like were really good but I specifically
really like Sue yin and her daughter a ton like
their performances when they spoke again like
I said no more native language or just their
relationship up I I love them the little girl is
like my favorite oh man that's great she's the
best I mean acting in general is of course very
difficult but I mean yeah especially when child
actors can do a great job it's even more like damn
like because he got a whole production of people
working it's it's already a tough enough job as is
so it's just you know I always give you know to my
my cap to children who can do a really like great
job and she was fantastic and I mean to me that
was the Crux of the whole heart of the film was
I mean obviously Statham was a star he was he was
very entertaining in the film but the relationship
between them like that got me so invested and to
the point where obviously I didn't want anything
to happen to either of them right um and obviously
I did even though I didn't know too much about
the dad just because I was so invested in the
daughter and her mother I was I still was saddened
by the father uh the grandpa um uh losing his life
scene with them that's sad and but I've changed my
mind she's she's my second favorite character the
is not afraid to swim in the middle of the ocean
yeah that takes guts like I wouldn't even swim
in the middle of the ocean so that's that's one
Brave dog but again for all the faults we we say
of the writers I'm glad they kept Pippin alive
at least yes and that little boy in his popsicle
survived yeah oh my gosh a popsicle was still
it just in such good form after all that drama
um I I mean I had a lot of fun I loved it when
they have that big shark on there that we think
is the Megalodon the Megalodon actually shows up
yeah oh that was fun oh I think my favorite shot
was the Megalodon coming out of the water after
Jason had stuck it in its eye and you actually
saw like the depth of field of how like large he
was outside of the water with Jason next to him I
loved that so much into the film's crit I thought
like visually a lot of the underwater stuff and
the cinematography under the water and also too
the technical the technological advances we saw
in like the the submarine stuff I mean I thought
that was all really well done like I was like I
want to go I mean I'm not even an underwater
program like you want to go on assuming there's
no megalodons out there I want to go on this side
like this looks great this is so this is a great
way to explore like the use of the budget in terms
of what they were doing underwater I thought it
was all great and even the stuff with the shark
I mean I I thought visually like it looked great
and I love the approach they they did at the
beginning with the Alf Alfred uh hitchcockian
uh and Steven Spielberg Jaws where you're not
really seeing the shark it's just not using it
not yeah you're using your mind to imagine what
what the shark is doing even though we can see
things that are happening to things underwater
but you kind of got to use your mind and I love
I love when they do stuff like that in shark films
yeah like the teeth imprint with the little girl
was awesome oh that was crazy and now I'm still
like was that the actual megalodon or was it the
smaller one it wasn't the smaller one because
then that would that's when they were like it's
not the same teeth marks right exactly that's what
that's where I mean because that's one I mean also
too the fact I was like I feel like this is too
soon and too anti-climactic for this to just be
the end already over but yeah that's because they
saw those bite marks that's where they were able
to uh where Jason Statham was able to say no the
bite marks were definitely bigger than the teeth
we're seeing here yeah and then also too I believe
that was a callback in reference as well to uh
Richard Dreyfus in Jaws playing Matt Hooper where
he was taking uh measurements of the tiger shark
and saying that that's not the bite marks on this
are different than the bite radius on uh Chrissy
Watkins the victim of the the first victim of in
the Jaws yeah yeah different teeth man I'd love to
hold the call I mean there was I'm sure there were
plenty I missed but I loved a lot of the callbacks
and references to jaws and I'm sure there were
other shark films that were being referenced but
obviously clearly Josh was yeah a major influence
on this film which it should be of course yeah not
only the greatest Shark film of all time it's one
of the greatest films of all time in my opinion
yeah yeah I agree I mean any last thoughts
I mean I had a lot of fun I'm I want to see
number two doesn't number two come out soon yeah I
believe very soon like this week or something yeah
something like that I mean I definitely want to
see but let us know in the comments yeah do you
want Tara and I to see it in theaters or would
you prefer we wait digitally and see it here
with you guys good question Andrew he needs to
know I need to know uh you guys can find me at
Tara Erickson all over the Internet Instagram all
this stuff what about you Igor 7-Eleven oh that's
cool do you hit 7-Eleven a lot it's my birthday I
knew it but I wanted him to go yep big gulp in it
that's not where you get your C4 no Amazon Amazon
that's where you buy everything I feel like yeah
nobody goes to the store and they're even closing
down Bed Bath and Beyond now all of them are
shutting down like what is this yeah it's fully
all right the world that we live in is is done
yeah everything's online nowadays and it wasn't
taken over by Megalodon it was taken over by
not really but kind of yeah yeah right
well that's it guys leave a like leave
a comment you know what to do also uh hold on
they're gonna have to cut this out but I think
I have to say something about patrons what do
they say at the end or are they just like Buy
to forget it's been a while since I've been on
so I don't remember the patreon don't forget
if you're not already Patron you should become a
patron because then you can sit with me and Andrew
watch the whole thing it's it's a blast of Rooney
we'll be back you guys tell us what you like
what you don't like what should we watch again we
love sharks and we love you that's it bye foreign